So today I will be
talking about
clustering in tidymodels.
It's something
I've been working with
Kelly Bodwin with
for the last half year or so.
And I'm very excited to come
here and talk to all of you
about it.
So before we go any
further, I want
to give a quick
additional introduction
to what I find most
important about tidymodels
as a framework.
And the three most
important things I see
is that it's consistent,
modular, and extensible.
It's consistent in a way
that any function that
returns a tibble will
always return a tibble
if it returns a fitted object
it will always be a fitted object
And any things like dimensions.
with respect to column
Names and raw numbers
will always stay the same.
So once you know what
a function outputs,
you can reliably code knowing
that will be the case.
Certainly it's
modular in the sense
that instead of having
one monster function
that will do a bunch
of preprocessing bit of
modeling inside a
cross-validation fold
and find the most optimal model.
According to some heuristics, we
instead create smaller objects
that you can then bind
together
Allowing us to easily.
Swap out and build a
more complete workflow.
And lastly, and for
me, most importantly,
is the idea of extensibility.
So tidymodels was built
from the ground up knowing
that we needed to make
it so other people could
build extensions and to make.
it much more
maintainable instead
of having one large part of
hundreds of thousands of code
that needs to all
be kept in sync.
Instead, we have smaller,
more focused packages
that could be
handled independently,
yet they all still work
wonderfully together.
This part is near
and dear to my heart
because this is how
I started working
with tidymodels
four years ago
When I started working on
my first extension pattern.
And now it let me up here
where I will talk about
another extension package
in front of all of you.
So when we think about
machine learning,
it's a wonderfully
ill-defined topic.
But one of the ways
we can think about it
is in the idea of unsupervised
and unsupervised setting.
So tidymodels right
now worked really well
in the supervised setting.
We can do classification,
we can do regression
as we just saw with.
We also are starting
to work on tools
to deal with censored
regression, which isn't even
on this diagram.
We also have tools in
the form of preprocessing
to deal with
dimensionality reduction,
having a lot of
variables turn it
into a smaller, hopefully
better set of variables.
But there's something
very glaring
right in the middle
of my diagram
right here that we haven't
been able to do for the longest
time.
And that's
what drove me to
work on this project
is we want to work
with clustering,
but it just didn't fit in.
And it wasn't even little
hacky to make it work.
It wasn't possible before to do
any kind of clustering models.
That's why I'm very
excited to gave
the first public
announcement that we're
introducing the tidyclust package.
So you're probably going to
have a couple of questions
or you're thinking,
something you like.
Yes finally, I needed this.
For years, people
have been asking.
People are trying to teach it.
We have a lot of people that
try to teach the classic intro
to statistics or
machine learning,
and you can do
almost everything.
in tidymodels and
then you have one.
week where you show clustering.
And it just feels all.
We're finally here.
Some of you might think
I really appreciate
that he's dressing in the
same theme as the slides.
But lastly.
A maybe more important
question is why
we're building another package.
And that comes from
some internal friction,
as I mentioned before,
that tidymodels just
wasn't built to do clustering.
It was built with
supervised models in mind.
And there wasn't really any
way to force it through.
It just didn't work.
And this is because of some
fundamental differences
between how
clustering models work
and how a typical
supervised models work.
And the main thing, which in
essence is a very fundamental
property, and it seems a
little bit simple
Most models have
outcomes and yeah,
of course they have outcomes.
But it meant that
every single piece
of code we have, more or less, is
written with outcomes in mind.
And it just meant that it
didn't work like we couldn't
make it work.
Because not only do you
clustering models not
have outcomes, we don't want
you to put in outcomes because
It would be a symptom you are
trying to do the wrong thing.
We also have in tidymodels
the idea
that we have clearly
defined predictions
which are in clustering a
very controversial topic
It will still talk
about it, but it still
is not the clearly most
clearly defined thing.
And lastly, related to
the idea of outcomes,
having a ground truth to
test your model against
means that you didn't
do that performance checking.
You can have a model, you
hide the outcome, predict on it
and see; do my predictions
align with the true values?
That made it very easy to do
normal performance metrics.
We can do no such thing
with clustering methods.
There are some ways
of seeing can we make.
But does this clustering
model appear to be solid?
But we don't have
any clear answer.
Nevertheless, we still move on
and try to do the best we can.
This means that.
We needed to do a
lot of work to port
over many of the
internals of tidymodels,
rewrite them from scratch
with the assumption
that there's no outcomes.
So it's a lot of parallel
code, but hopefully it
means for all of you that it
will be a seamless transition
as possible.
If you're already familiar with
tidymodels, i would wager that
by reading the vignettes we
have coming up later today.
On the pkgdown site,
you can get up
and running with tidyclust
in an hour or two.
because
We found a fairly
good transition.
To show how some of
this work I will use
some very exciting data set.
So it's a data set of
dates as in the fruit.
And it is
Features extracted from images.
So they have a bunch of
images of dates and then they
calculated various things of
those
Images so that the area
will be the number of pixels
that contain the fruit.
We have perimeter, eccentricity.
We also have various
things about the RGB
of those images.
So there's a lot
happening in here.
And we're hoping to
see if just by having
these visual metrics about.
These dates if we can
pull out some clusters.
Two things you will
notice about this data is
some of these values have
quite different ranges.
So something like the
area is in the order
of hundreds of thousands and
something like eccentricity
is quite a low value.
So if our clustering model has
any type of scale sensitivity,
we need to deal with that.
Additionally, we
have a lot of these.
Predictors being
quite correlated.
So generally for most shapes.
We have that the area
parameter convex
areas of roughly related
and likewise something
like to tell us if there's a lot
of blue in a picture that might
not be as much of the other color.
So we have a lot of
correlations which we can
see in this correlation matrix.
It's a little too
small to actually see
what different
things are, but we
are seeing huge chunks of highly
correlated variables and highly
decorrelated data
variables, so we might
want to have to deal
with that as well.
So we start out the same
way we do in parsnip
by creating a clustering
model specification.
So here we are doing a simple
k-means and we write it out.
And with that k-means
Cluster specification.
We have yet another mode here.
We talk about a partition.
So we say a partition is
when every observation will
be assigned one and
only one cluster.
Later down the line.
We want to expand
our work surface
to use extractive
clustering where.
Any one observation can
be in 0 or more clusters.
So there is work on that
in the horizon.
But how we can specify a
cluster specification here using
the default engine
in the stats package.
We can also set the
number of clusters.
We can change the engine or
add engine specific things.
Another thing we
really try to work
hard on as we do in parsnip
and other packages is have.
More descriptive names.
So instead of having k
and h, we will instead
name it something like
num_clusters or tot_height.
So you don't have to as
much jargon moving around.
With this model
specification, we
can now work with the
rest of tidymodels.
So here we are creating
a specification
and we said we wanted
to normalize the data.
I'm dealing with
the correlations
by applying some PCA keeping
the most variable principal
components and we
can do it easy.
Put it into a workflow
and fit this workflow.
And if you take a
quick note, you will
see that this is very,
very similar to everything
else we're doing in tidymodels.
The only two
differences is instead
of specifying as a parsnip
object we instead creating
our tidyclust object.
And in the recipe we are
not specifying an outcome.
But everything else
should work smoothly.
So there's very little new
things for you to learn.
Once we have a fitted workflow,
we now have an object.
We want to do certain
calculations with it
straight out, see
what happens inside.
Traditionally a lot
of that work was
delegated into broom package,
while amazing, has been drawing
a lot and have drawing pain.
So we are rewriting a
lot of that functionality
on our new engines to
stay consistent and work
the way we want it to.
So some of the
things we can do
is pull out what cluster
each of the observations
were found in our
cluster model.
We always did a tibble
back here named .cluster,
so it's always the same.
Additionally, we have done
some reconciliation
of the cluster names.
So in a case like k-means
the cluster is a random,
but we are stopping some of that
randomness from coming through.
So you're more likely to.
actually have consistent
clusters across bootstraps.
Another thing we
can do is pull out
where those classes are located.
We can do that with
extract_centroids.
But then we can note
here that since we
had a workflow with a recipe,
the centroid are based
on where the data.
Centroids are based in
the data space that
was passed to the cluster
model, which in this case
was the PCs that came
out of the recipe.
And lastly, we are
a little on the edge
by saying that some
of these engines
also allow for prediction.
So prediction is a little
bit of a touchy subject,
but in every type of
models, we have
to describe what we
actually mean by it.
And in the case of k-means
it means which cluster
centroid are you closest to?
And this works.
again with the
whole workflow.
So the preprocessing
will happen.
So you don't have so you
don't have those sneaky data
leakage that happens
by doing PC before
and everything like that.
While I talked about how
something like metrics
can be quite hard to
calculate, there still
is a number of metrics
that we would like to do.
So in the same
style as yardstick,
we have a number
of metrics that are
specific to these
cluster fits.
So here we have a function that
calculates the total of total
in sum of squared errors.
And to calculate that
it's not just a matter
of comparing an outcome to.
A ground truth.
Instead, we are
calculating a metric
based on the centroid
and the observations
that this metric is summing up.
How far the points
are from the clusters.
And in the same style,
if we have multiple,
we can combine them in a
cluster metric set
to calculate multiple
metrics as one.
So so far I talked a lot
about that just a fitted one
model that to do that
where we arbitrarily
set the number of
clusters to be five.
But ideally we would
like to find out
how many clusters there are.
We'll never know, but maybe
we can see which clusters
would be the best ones.
So we're going
onto tuning so we
can specify that the
number of clusters
should be tuned to try a
bunch of different things.
Instead of a trade
of different values,
we say, I want to see something
between 1 and 10 plus,
as would probably be best
as a fairly small data set.
If not, we can move on.
And then we have our
function to cluster
that has almost the same user
interface as.
The tune functions you're
familiar with from tune
and from tune.
So you pass in a workflow or
a cluster specification.
You give it some resamples
and a grid of values.
And here we can also specify
some cluster metrics.
So the only difference here
than your usual workflow
is you want to use tune
cluster instead of tune
grid, and then
you can optionally
pass in a custom set
of metric functions.
And then once all
that runs clean,
you get back the
same type of results
that you had for most
of the tune functions.
So you tend to let metrics, to
let predictions select best by
or to plot and so on.
I'm not saying you should
do select best because as we
have here in a k-means
when the number of clusters
go up.
This metric will always go down
that is just a reality.
But this could easily be
combined with something
like a ggplot to create an elbow
chart or any other diagnostic
you may mean you may want to do.
That's all I have for you today.
There's more.
What? over here.
We have some India.
I'm going to try to
emerge as soon as I can
after this thought.
The main takeaway
I want for you is I
want you to use the package.
We're still in very
early development.
Most of the foundation
is here in the sense
that everything works,
hopefully, right?
Yeah but I want to know
what you want to do,
because we still are missing
more types of metrics, engines
and models.
So I want to hear all
of that from your.